[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na Aren seu
podcast semanal onde a gente indica
troca ideias sobre conteúdos que a gente
leu ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo a
visão de produto PR discussão eu sou
Artur e aia tá no tamanho de uma jaca de
até uns 30 cm a mini jaca né é uma mini
jaca e eu sou a essa semana eu tô
passando frio velho hoje tá um friozinho
não tá frio pra caramba tá muito frio
nossa velho tá do Hoje eu fui de bike
por trabalho eu tive que uma hora parar
e transformar meu casaco meio que numa
luva sabe Nossa eu fui comprar pão de
manhã e eu tava tipo de chinelo calça
casaco tipo as minhas partes
desprotegidas do corpo elas sofreram
assim é ai e no programa de hoje a gente
vai falar dos seguintes assuntos o o
presente o futuro dos produtos de ai e a
relação de ai com Excel é
também e também a gente vai falar de um
assunto que já foi polêmico há muito
tempos atrás mas até hoje continua né
existe um mundo além das squads do
Spotify ol aí bons assuntos hoje hein
mas antes da gente entrar nele
hojeando não meu caro Watson
é bom Relembrando aqui vocês né dia 24
de agosto tem a quinta edição do curso
de pensamento crítico e analítico com o
Dudu Magalhães então se você tem dúvidas
aí de como conectar as as coisas que
você faz no produto aí com os
indicadores financeiros vem fazer que é
o dia inteiro falando disso então você
vai sair fazendo sabendo fazer até uma
análise de impacto lá para mostrar que a
mexida no botão pode gerar um montão de
dindim é ou não ou não ou não que é [__]
mas minimamente você vai aprender a
fazer contas de padaria que a gente Vira
e Mexe fala aqui nos Episódios e que
inclusive né Tem um episódio onde que a
a Alice fala muito das contas de padaria
dela né total e também no dia 14 de
setembro aí é lá no mês que vem
vai ter a quarta Edição do curso de ai
para PMs na prática Ai que é um assunto
que a gente fala aqui sempre né Então tá
aí se você quer aprender a o behind the
scenes de criar produtos com ai o que
que é como usar a ai no dia a dia para
facilitar seu dia a dia inclusive nosso
ikira aqui vai est lá contando também né
como que ele fez o GPT para facilitar a
vida dele na hora de mapear os eventos
aí então é isso Jabá contextualizado
Jabá lá detalhado e o descontinho Maroto
que só ouvintes tem tá aqui na descrição
com 15% de desconto hein Olha aí
Descontão Agora sim bora lá pra pauta
Bora
[Música]
lá bom a gente vai começar o programa de
hoje não é bem com um conteúdo
específico na verdade virou um mix de
conteúdos que fez a gente trazer essa
pauta
presunçosa né de dizer aqui qual que é o
futuro da eia aqui nesse programa Hoje
Artur a gente vai bater uma martelo e
vai prever o futuro obviamente a gente
vai errar mas tudo bem é tipo no início
do ano a gente fez lá Episódio as
previsões que ninguém pediu né então Car
gente tem que voltar no final do ano
nesse né para ver o que que a gente
errou o que que a gente ass o último
programa do ano vai ser esse vai ser o
recap o que erramos e o que acertamos
Mas vamos seguir aqui né o conteúdo
principal que inspirou essa pauta foi um
texto do benedict Evans chamado thei
Summer Mas tem várias outras referências
que a gente vai deixar aí nos
comentários inclusive as que falam sobre
ai e exel como o Artur falou que a gente
puxa daqui a pouco quem ouve o podcast
há mais tempo aqui vai perceber que a
gente continua trazendo notícias dei a
gente tem trazido até com bastante
frequência nos últimos programas né mas
tem muito menos produto e grandes coisas
empolgantes quanto no início não sei se
você tem esse mesmo sentimento Artur Mas
eu sinto que no início parecia que toda
semana tinha uma parada muito [__] e não
é como se agora não tivesse tipo tem o
flux agora que é o novo modelo de imagem
que tá gerando imagem Super realista
super bem e tal mas tem esse sentimento
de que as coisas estão evoluindo mas não
dando grandes saltos como era antes e
esse TR os pontos bem legais eh de onde
a gente tá E nessa onda de eii e para
onde a gente pode estar indo e para
começar acho que o dado que puxa para
mim uma discussão que eu acho muito
interessante que ele apresenta no texto
é que de 25 a 30% das pessoas pelo menos
ali em países desenvolvidos já usaram o
chat GPT especificamente e esse é o copo
meio cheio do dado né você pensar assim
que um produto lançado em 18 meses
depois 1/3 da população 20% da população
já tinha usado Ele E aí veio o copo meio
vazio só por volta de 10% das pessoas
que conhecem faz o uso semanal e uso
pode ser qualquer coisa aqui né não não
tem uma discriminação ali do que que eu
uso e outra ideia legal que vem desse
texto é que os produtos de ai eles meio
que pularam a curva de adoção
tradicional né aquela famosa curva S que
tem um monte de texto de produto e eles
tiveram um awareness grande de início
mas eles não passaram por essa fase de
descobrir o product Market Fit né de pô
começar pequenininho num nicho com
pessoas ali adopters e descobrindo Fit e
escalando Tipo ele meio
escalou é ele meio escalou de tipo todo
mundo conhece muita gente já ouviu falar
e agora a gente tá meio que pensando né
então já falei um monte aqui vou abrir
para você trazer seus comentários aí e
aí depois a gente fala mais em cima cara
um Que bom o benedict Evan cara a News
dele o conteúdo são sempre conteúdos
muito bons né já seg muito tempo eu é um
dos caras que eu recomendo bastante
assim e eu gosto muito que ele sempre
traz boas analogias assim boas
comparações né isso até porque né O cara
tá aí Ah ele éa miliano né fazendo
análise de mercado velho ele para mim
ele é o ele é o o cara do strater só que
resumido assim tipo é mas cara Acho que
alguns dados que ele trouxe que são
relevantes assim cara Demorou mais de 20
anos para 20% dos retails dos Estados
Unidos estarem online né total e foi foi
até aquela coisa daquela curva que [__]
passou da da linha de tendência na
pandemia e depois voltou pra linha de
tendência né exato só a gente tá falando
assim 20% dos estabelecimentos tá ligado
é [__] é cara 1/5 tá ligado a gente que
é cronicamente online tipo achei que tá
tudo online né exato mas não é real
outra outra coisa que ele fala né sobre
pô a Apple e o primeiro iPhone né
Demorou cara 12 a primeira versão os
primeiros 12 meses vendeu só 5 milhões
de device eh nos primeiros 12 meses e
hoje cara não tinha App Store pô não
tinha app
ST inclusive Não estava nem nos planos
de App Store porque eles acreditavam ser
tudo we né exato então assim essas
coisas nem sempre vem na velocidade que
a gente quer cara sei que a gente é
nativo digital e a gente é sempre o
lance lado da dopamina de querer tudo
para ontem de quando a gente acessa As
Coisas d lá não sabe dá um Google e já
tem a resposta a gente acha que isso
funciona para todas as coisas né E aí eu
acho que ai seja o chpt acho
principalmente chpt mas assim é a
primeira coisa que a gente tá vendo em
em larga escala assim sabe da nossa
geração eu acho que do tipo sei lá o
iPhone eh quando a gente se deu por
adultos é eu era adolescente ainda é E
aí quando a gente virou adulto pô beleza
a gente sabe que o iPhone vende para
[__] que não sei o qu Nossa então
sempre foi assim e não e não foi né que
inclusive vou até mandar um salve aqui
pro Johnny que ele fala do negócio do
efeito Mandela lembra É verdade é
verdade então eu acho que essa coisa de
a é meio que o efeito Mandela aí de tipo
assim nossa beleza não ai agora todo
mundo usa todo mundo sabe funciona todas
as empresas que usam ai vai ser Unic tá
na boca e tá na mão de todo mundo né
exato É cara Essa parada é muito doida
né Porque de fato a a gente de novo
somos pessoas cronicamente online
estamos ali no Twitter a gente é bem
early Adopter das coisas e testa tipo ah
você vê em toda sua bolha em todo lugar
que você consome notícia só se fala
daquilo então é muito fácil você entrar
nessa Câmara de eco aqui que não é uma
câmara de eco negativa de pô todo mundo
sabe o que que é isso todo mundo Manja
tá todo mundo usando e não velho é pelo
pelo contrário assim até Tem bastante
gente que tem noção do que é ou sabe
vagamente mas usando usando mesmo é
pouco isso quando a gente fala da pessoa
física quando a gente fala da pessoa
jurídica aqui da empresa ele traz isso
no texto também né que tem uma pesquisa
lá que as empresas estão
projetando deployar coisas de ai para
2026 assim então [__] aí você vai falar
não mas tem um monte de empresa que tá
usando já vi um monte de texto sobre tem
mas quantos desses casos de uso são
substituições inteiras de workflows e
não testes ou poques porque teste Pock
tem um monte de gente fazendo a centro
tá ganhando Rig de dinheiro lá para
fazer poque teste para um monte de
empresa mas quantas empresas pegarem Pô
vou subir substituir esse workflow
inteiro aqui que era feito por humanos
ou feito por outros sistemas por eais
sabe então é o Deploy disso no
corporativo demora muito mais né Pois é
e é isso né aí beleza as empresas podem
um pouco se se aproveitar das outras que
vão mais rápido fazer isso e contratar
elas né é o próprio caso da docket a
gente tem clientes bem enterprise bem
grandes mas se eles forem criar uma
estrutura lá usar tecnologia para
otimizar alguma parte do o processo
deles demoraria muito tempo então eles
usam a docket é plá que tipo a gente já
usa eii já usa um mon de coisa estão em
curto o caminho que é um pouco do que a
gente tem tem visto também isso né as
empresas fazendo as o comprando outras
empresas que tem esse pedaço isso tem a
hotm fez isso também a gente os clientes
do no São clientes muito mais
tradicionais né ali bancos e tal
instituições financeiras na hotmart não
que é na gente mesmo uma forma de
acelerar a criação de coisas foi comprar
outras empresas que que tem essa já
tinam ess ess expertise produto lançado
e tal é Enfim acho que uma outra coisa
que ele fala bastante lá é que os dois
artigos falam bastante no dia dois lá
que é que llm por si só não é um produto
né e é isso assim como que isso fica
mais visível pro do tipo o fluxo ali tem
toda a parte de o X tem como que deixa
isso para de fato as pessoas utilizarem
assim como a gente já comentou em vários
episódios tipo Beleza cada atualização
do chat PT ele mata 20 30 startups que
ele mesmo criou né ele mesmo deu espaço
ali para serem criadas mas que é isso
que que e aí o outro artigo lá fala isso
né Que cara é tipo Excel né você é fácil
de utilizar mas assim não significa é
fácil de começar a usar isso é muito bom
mas que nem sempre a interface vai ser
melhor então pode ser que tipo seja o
Excel ali por trás o que a gente viu
milhões de empresas até hoje antigamente
usavam o Excel por trás ele para
organizar alguma coisa e hoje em dia
tipo não não tem mais isso e a parte de
ai é a mesma coisa a gente viu muitas
coisas aí que no final estão rodando por
trás ali é o chpt só ou o cloud ou
qualquer outro né no artigo do Ever lá
ele fala Car a gente lança uma parada
que por trás é o cloud você pode fazer
abrir o cloud lá e fazer a pergunta lá
para ele que ele vai te dar a resposta
só que é isso Nem toda pessoa quer fazer
isso no eu vou até trazer um exemplo bem
no contexto da docked assim a gente tava
querendo lançar um produto a gente
lançou né um produto que é para leitura
de qualquer tipo de documento a gente
tem os nossos documentos especializados
E aí a gente foi lá e fez um para uma
leitura genérica para interpretar
qualquer tipo de documento mesmo uhum só
assim só que a versão muito simples eu
poderia simplesmente lá colocar cara
pergunta aqui o texto tá aberto e
pergunta aqui o que que é mas cara de
novo nossos clientes são enterprise e
tudo mais que a gente fez foi não assim
eu vou guiar o usuário Então assim tá
aqui ó tá aqui escreve o o que o campo
que você quer invés de per de tipo
escrever um monte de coisa só me fala o
campo e aí por trás a gente faz todo um
processo e tudo mais mas pro usuário ele
não precisava disso tudo tá ligado uhum
então que eu acho que encaixa nisso
assim que como a gente faz essas
adaptações e é isso quanto mais a gente
entende o produto entende a dor nem o
produto Nem entende ador do do do
cliente do usuário o nome que você
queira dar mais fácil vai ficar para
como você vai tipo guiar ou instruir o
usuário seja na interface seja em
instruções seja o que quer que seja É eu
gosto muito dessa comparação com Excel
velho porque o Excel é o maior software
já já inventado no mundo né tipo
qualquer coisa dá para você fazer na
Excel é prático e é o que você falou ele
é muito básico para você começar a usar
e ele pode se tornar uma coisa muito
complexa E aí o que vários desses textos
falam né que toda vez que você tem um
uma planilha que é uma pessoa que dá
manutenção ou que tem uma série de
automatizações Rolando nela ali aquilo
ali vira um size basicamente vira um BB
size né e se você pensar cara boa parte
dos SS que se tornaram grandes que
surgiram nos últimos anos ou até mais
antigo tipo que que é um CRM um seios
Force da vida senão obviamente eu tô
simplificando muito aqui né mas cara um
monte de registros de contatos e
anotações sobre esses contatos né então
um CRM é isso cara o que que é o Gira
senão algo que você poderia fazer na
Excel ali você poderia controlar seus
sprints suas tarefas faz o shudo
whatever com tudo no Excel alguém foi lá
e falou [__] não quero fazer isso aqui
na Excel quero preciso de um software
especializado para isso para ele poder
ir mais profundo nesse caso de uso nessa
dor e eu consigo enxergar muito llm
sendo isso sabe é a primeira interface
que a gente foi exposto delas é uma
interface muito simples é um box de chat
que você digita e interage assim quando
como você abre o Excel tem células
linhas e colunas que são muitoo simples
de ter agir mas conforme você vai
aprofundando você pode criar coisas
extremamente complexas sistemas inteiros
automatizações E aí vão surgir softwares
que são construídos em cima disso então
o que era sei lá no Último Verão você
ser um ai rapper era um xingamento eu
acho que na real ser um ai rapper é ser
um size b2b dos anos 20 que a gente tá
agora sabe talvez então eu eu consigo
imaginar um mundo Onde é isso existe uma
pessoa que dá manutenção num GPT
específico que tem umas automações que
roda lá nele ninguém sabe [__] isso aqui
tem potencial de virar um software
separado e que que é um negócio grande
por si só sabe eu gosto de chamar isso
de o custo da conveniência né cara é
exatamente sempre vai ter alguém
disposto a pagar por alguma parada que
ela não quer aprender que ela quer que
ela quer usar algo para fazer tipo mas
ela não quer ter que que às vezes é uma
coisa que é só marginalmente um pouco
melhor tá ligado boa parte dos Sites que
a gente usa no dia a dia é isso não é
que não dá para fazer de outro jeito ele
é marginalmente melhor do que o outro
tipo você usar aí de um trelo para um
gira [__] é uma grande coisa da vida não
é marginalmente melhor mas tem empresas
que pagam o ris de dinheiro por esse
marginalmente melhor sabe é
[Música]
isso segundo conteúdo de hoje é uma
apresentação feita pelo Nan iu acho que
é esse o jeito de falar que é head de
produto do liner a gente tava falando do
gira aí né o linear é um concorrente do
gira é famosinho aí no no Silicon Valley
e foi uma palestra que ele deu no config
no evento do figma que a gente falou
aqui no episódio recente tem um episódio
falando sobre Então procura aí no seu
feed o nome da Talk é the Hair loon
tomato Org shart que é um nome muito
estranho para tratar da ideia central de
que a forma como as empresas se
organizam ela reflete diretamente no
produto que é entregue pro usuário e
muitas empresas acabam otimizando para
ter uma topologia de time bonitinha
tradicional da moda ao invés de otimizar
pro que ela quer entregar pro cliente de
fato E aí é o herlon tomato porque eu
não sei se você viu Artur mas o herlon
tomeiro aparentemente é um tipo de
tomate que ele é muito saboroso E aí ele
fala que as empresas eles otimizam para
ter um tomate bonitinho redondinho ao
invés desse ele é muito saboroso mas ele
é meio estranho ele parece uma tangerina
assim então é é essa analogia aqui e aí
para puxar a discussão aqui o que eu
achei interessante principalmente
pensando que a gente tem muitas pessoas
que ouvem o programa que tão estágio
avançado de carreira é que a gente
deveria ser muito intencional e discutir
bastante a organização dos times de
produto e tecnologia não só pegar e
copiar o modelo de squads modelo F gerar
do modelo Spotify mas eu acho que um
negócio que dificulta isso e que eu acho
que a maior parte das pessoas viveu
poucas experiências com outros tipos de
organização empresas a gente sempre fala
aqui de ciclo de produto de cinto de
ferramentas né de que você precisa
ganhar experiência ali para passar por
diferentes experiências de produto para
enriquecer esse seu cinto e às vezes
você vai passar por n empresas e n
ciclos diferentes de produto no mesmo
tipo de topologia né de empresa que não
vai te dar não vai te dar esse
conhecimento e esse olhar crítico e aí
você vai acabar indo pela literatura e
pelas experiências muito parecidas que
você já viveu e eu te pergunto meu
querido Artur você já chegou na fase de
ser inimigo dos squads porque às vezes
eu me sinto assim às vezes eu falo assim
nossa V cansado cansado de sad e dessa
organização
assim ai
24 você chega querendo demolir os squads
já
Caral cara demolir os squads não só que
de novo como a gente sempre fala aqui
cara não existe uma receita de bolo na
prática ag a Teoria é muito diferente tá
ligado que a resposta mais PM possível
né Depende o famoso depende não cara mas
é até menos depende é que velho no final
das contas é isso na prática é muito
diferente sacou porque isso lá Ai nossa
porque você tem que ter os times que
fazem isso e que fazem aquilo e [__] você
tem que ter as multidisciplinaridades e
blá blá blá só que pô aí é isso aí você
vai lá beleza tem um time que cuida de
uma parte mas qualquer time pode fazer
Deploy não aí você vai o time lá que faz
cuida uma parte vai ter que toda hora
parar para olhar lá o código do outro aí
então assim já não é já não é todo mundo
pode mexer essa [__]
porque é isso então é isso aí [__] Faz
Sentido deixar não faz deixa num
contexto lá só e tal então assim ou
então nossa o time todo o time precisa
ter um designer precisa ter um pian
precisa ter um tipo os Dev precisa ter
um k PR fala você tem que botar aquela
caixinha bonitinha assim de todos os
times eles têm o mesmo formato com as
mesmas mesmas disciplinas é e não é e
uma coisa que ele fala muito no coisa
que cara tem Cape size e scope né e é
isso cara é ent Endo quanto mais você
entende isso assim cara nem todo o time
vai precisar ter todos todas as
disciplinas na docket eu tenho times que
não t design Uhum eu tenho outros times
que tem putz tem time que tem machine
learning tem outros times que não e
então assim é isso e assim não é ah
nossa tem que ter dois back dois front
dois q a do sei lá o qu não cara cada um
vai depender mas antes de você chegar
nessa parte tá bom Quais são as pessoas
quais são as disciplinas que a gente
precisa aqui nesse time e até acho que
depois chega em qual o Skill que a gente
precisa das pessoas desse time um passo
atrás é isso é entendeu Tá bom qual que
é o escopo que a gente vai ter para cada
time ou quais os escopos que a gente
quer atacar para saber quais os times
que você pode ou não ter E aí você vai
falar beleza Qual que é o formato que eu
vou terem cada um desses times que você
vai chegar tá bom qual que é o perfil
das pessoas que eu preciso para esse
time Cara eu acho que até antes disso né
o que que é importante pra sua empresa
ou não né tipo real nem
T é nem tudo tem o mesmo grau de
importância aqui que eu lembro há muito
tempo atrás cara na época da da tem bice
teve um momento que a gente literalmente
descontinuou o time do tipo Pivot ele
para tocar uma outra frente não que a
frente que ele tava tocando era
importante a gente tava tocando esse
time tocava engajamento e a gente foi
tocar uma outra frente que era mais
importante só por quê Porque naquele
momento pra companhia fazia mais sentido
a gente atacar uma parte do que a outra
né então eu acho que é isso cara quanto
mais a gente vai vai descobrindo isso e
vai vai falando que não é só a
literatura não é só colocar lá o
videozinho e ver que aquilo vai
funcionar você vai testando coisas
diferentes né e uma das coisas que eu
sempre curti muito e um dos motivos da
gente ter criado a prod carena e tudo
mais e é isso assim é tá bom Como que
outras empresas estão fazendo sabe eí
você fala tá bom pô mas me fala por que
que vocês estão fazendo desse jeito pô
porque aqui o contexto é x YZ Eu lembro
quando a gente decidiu quebrar mudar a
estrutura da da iuse porque quando a
gente começou já falei em alguns outros
episódios aqui mas a gente tinha antes
por produto era por tipo de seguro e
tinha um Squad de mobile aí passou um
ano depois tal a gente falou Pô cara sei
lá acho que a gente tá encontrando
algumas coisas aqui que talvez a gente
tenha outros pontos agora que talvez
essa estrutura não não sirva mais uhum e
aí eu fui conversar com a galera lá do
do booking eu tava Tipo pô com uma
galera do Até conversei com uma galera
do Spotify também Conversei com com uma
galera tipo de outras empresas aqui do
Brasil e pô cada uma tava com um formato
para resolver o problema e era muito
assim cara é o nosso formato aqui é
porque a gente quer resolver x y z então
a gente optou por esse formato massa e
aí a gente voltou PR casa e falou tá bom
até inclusive mandar um salve pra Loren
aqui a gente sentou e trocou uma ideia
falou assim tá bom qual que é o formato
que a gente O que que a gente quer
resolver Quais são os os os novos
desafios que a gente tem agora tá bom
então para esses desafios talvez a
estrutura não faça mais sentido Tá bom
então bora lá ver como que vai ser isso
né nessa nessa a gente antes tinha um
time que que
tinha concentrando todos os devs de
mobile Android IOS etc quando a gente
fez isso a gente quebrou isso não tinha
mais o Square a gente acabou com o sad
mobile isso e foi quebrando em cada um
dos times tinah diciplinas em cada um
então já mudou a estrutura do das squads
também por conta disso teve Squad que
nem teve nem tinha mobile Então eu acho
que é trazendo de novo aqui né esse que
não é o One size Fits All no final das
contas é quanto mais você sabe quais são
os problemas que você vai resolver mais
você vai ver qual que é a estrutura que
você vai ter é eu acho que essa é a
parada importante é a intencionalidade é
você na hora de montar os times entender
para que você tá otimizando tipo o que
você quer com aquilo Qual que é o
objetivo esse falou da US eu lembrei
também Dea discussão que a gente teve na
Pier bem parecida assim que a Pier
começou só com seguro de celular né
então a gente era dividido por jornadas
ali então jornada de aquisição jornada
de de experiência do cliente ali jornada
de sinistro E aí chegou o momento que a
gente foi criar mais um produto que era
o seguro de carro e aí a gente teve essa
discussão sobre a gente deveria ir para
um formato de se dividir por produto e
ou a gente deveria manter o formato por
jornada e aí a gente tá cara tava sendo
muito intencional na discussão de que
que significa a para um formato pro
produto [__] você consegue se
especializar muito mais você consegue é
entregar um produto muito mais tayor
made para aquele contexto e tal qual que
é o tradeoff aqui é que você começa a
separar os dois produtos e aí Muito
provavelmente as experiências começam a
não fazer sentido então quando a galera
fala tipo você chipa a estrutura
organizacional da sua empresa é esse
tipo de coisa se você cara é dividido
por produto por exemplo Muito
provavelmente você vai começar a ter
produtos que andam para caminhos
diferentes ali eventualmente você começa
a ter inconsistências às vezes porque é
difícil você manter E aí na época a
gente até tomou uma decisão de por um
tempo ficar por produto depois voltar
pra jornada muito por causa disso para
manter a consistência Tipo pô tem que
ter alguém que tá olhando a jornada de
aquisição dos dois produtos porque a
gente quer ser uma empresa multiprodutos
Então faz sentido que pense a jornada de
aquisição dos dois ou n produtos que
venham a ter no futuro sobre isso eu
acho que isso é é muito muito legal e
essa parada de você cara ter muita
clareza de qual que é a principal coisa
que a sua empresa faz e que
necessariamente precisa mais recurso né
E às vezes tipo você bota mais gente ali
ou tem mais vagas ali mesmo que você não
precise porque é onde eventualmente vai
precisar é onde vai ter mais feedback
para você iterar em cima mais problema
acontecendo né e tudo bem Se tiver
outros times que estão menos servidos
ali e [__] tem várias coisas legais que
ele fala nesse nesse vídeo que eu já vi
assim tipo ah tem aquele time que ele
claramente cuida de uma coisa menos
importante mas ele tem uma estrutura
igual o time que cuida da coisa mais
importante E aí todo mundo que entra
entra naquele time para aprender mas vai
aprendendo sobre a coisa menos
importante da empresa ao invés de ir
para um negócio relevante e tem o famoso
[__] então a gente precisa adicionar o
KR né então precisa Precisamos pramos do
sistema de metas aqui para resolver né
meu Deus eu anotei essa parte aqui
porque [__] que pariu cara Essa é a
minha
eterna eterna discussão eterna briga
assim cara é isso n as pessoas acham que
que é isso colocar o KR vai fazer agora
todo mundo
do
akr e Pô eu acho que a gente pode fazer
um episódio depois cara só falando sobre
mitos mitos sobre
okrs só dando reate em
okr ai mas é isso e e outra parada legal
assim que ele fala é cara de onde vem né
Essas coisas e porque que a gente segue
né então [__] ah tem o two Box pizza Tim
do da Amazon os squads do Spotify o High
output Management né que ele até falando
ele até falando no vídeo pô é um livro
de 83 num cara que era ce da Intel e e a
gente aplica as coisas hoje como se a
gente tivesse em 1983 ainda né e não não
adaptado ao GJ hoje [__] Não tô dizendo
aqui que o Royal F Management não tem
coisas boas mas já tem coisas que tem
que ser transportadas pro seu tempo né e
obviamente você ganhar ali conhecimento
de coisas para você pensar o que é
melhor pro seu contexto não só tirar de
um lugar e aplicada é o exemplo que dava
lá pô o r [__] foi feito na época que não
tinha nem internet direito não tinha
Slack WhatsApp afins né se fosse uma
empresa que fazia chip né velho outra
parada é então é isso eu acho engraçado
que ele troca ali o o Grove pelo ce da
nvia o Grove tinha tipo One One com
todos os report direto ce da nvia tem 40
reports
direto [__] É eu acho que essa é uma
grande grande coisa tipo cara a real é
que não existe estrutura certa né acho
que é existe a que vai funcionar pro
momento que você tá cara é e eu acho que
é o que você falou que você fez né E que
eu acho que sempre vale a pena conversar
com as pessoas né tipo Pega alguém que
que já passou por o estágio de empresa
que sua empresa tá um desafio parecido
coisa assim e pega referência que cara
todo mundo que já fez algo fez cagada
para qualquer coisa na vida se você fez
algo na sua vida Muito provavelmente
você fez uma cagada em relação a aquilo
no trabalho não é diferente a gente
aprende com as cagadas então se você
puder aprender com as cagadas dos outros
a pessoa vai dizer [__] não faz isso
porque ou até [__] faz isso mas toma
cuidado com ess ess negócio aqui que
pode dar errado é E aí mais uma vez acho
que vale falar um aspecto que você falou
do do do lance de
intencionalidade que inclusive Citando
de novo a Alice aqui quando ela tava
falando de estrutura lá quando a gente
trocou a ideia com ela ela falou cara a
única certeza é que a gente não vai a
gente não é o povo a gente não vai
resolver todos os problemas mas quanto
mais intencional você tá sendo mais você
vai saber Quais os problemas que você
precisa resolver naquele momento pode
ter uns que vão cair você não vai
resolver e tá tudo bem mas o combinado
não sai caro né Então tá todo mundo
ciente que ó galera temos esse problema
sim temos Vamos resolver ele não então
tá todo mundo por qu porque esse outro
problema aqui a gente precisa resolver
muito mais do que esse
Então bora exato exat e você não precisa
morrer abraçado com a sua estrutura né
ela pode e deve mudar conforme a empresa
muda o mundo muda então tipo não é
porque você escolheu de um jeito que
você precisa ir abraçado com ele até o
fim da vida exato cara e acho que Pô
Essa é uma das coisas que que há uma
outra analogia que é muito falada né que
toda empresa é um organismo né e é isso
cara toda estrutura ela ela tá
suscetível a mudanças e depende muito de
como tá o mercado tem hora que é o
mercado e o seu Business especificamente
né n pô tem hora que é isso cara pô
estamos um período de recessão então pô
Provavelmente você vai ter que enxugar e
fazer mais com menos estamos num período
de vacas gordas então pô vamos ter mais
estruturas aqui mais times mais apostas
mais mais pontos para fazer enfim
depende muito e é isso aí você vai ter
que fazer esse tunning de acordo com
isso então Caraca tem um [__] problema
aqui agora vai sair uma legislação nova
aí puto tem que não sei o que aqui
beleza Ou então pô vamos fechar uma
parceria Milionária aqui com alguma
empresa Então cara precisamos focar
nisso aqui pega Fulano beltrano C clando
aqui para um time para fazer o o
Avengers aqui para para resolver sabe e
é isso teórico o Avengers não vai fazer
mais sentido tá ligado e beleza é
engraçado tipo as situações empresa
realmente só muda de endereço aí porque
to
situações cpj tudo até as analogias vou
pegar o Avengers aqui analogias do nosso
tempo claramente né porque no passado
deveri ser devia ser outros ser os Power
Rangers ou ou o Ultra antiga lá o super
amigos é isso tá bom né Já estamos
devaneando a Caraca não esse episódio tá
sacan
[Música]
viu falando nisso fal não tem nenhuma
conexão mas eu ia falar pra gente ir
pros produtos da semana vamos lá o meu
produto da semana vou começar aqui não é
não vou começar aqui mas cara eu tô
usando Comecei a usar um app recente e a
minha experiência tá sendo muito boa com
ele por isso que eu vou falar é que é o
lite eu nem sei se é assim que fala mas
é que eu tô pensando é Lite mesmo é qual
que é o de que tem a balança de saúde
pistas isso isso e é então pô cara
comecei a usar recente mas assim eu tô
tendo uma
experiência muito boa tô explica aí pra
galera que não sabe o que que é o que
que é o lit Cara não sei se eu vou
explicar muito bem não mas assim Basic
faz o seu melhor vai lá tá bom vou
lá o máximo que eu conseguir vamos lá
mas cara basicamente é um app que você
tem né ali o tem um app também né mas
ele é uma empresa que tem você tem
nutricionista Você tem psicólogo e
outras coisas aqui para para fazer o seu
acompanhamento ali aí Eles te dão uma
entregam uma balança para você para você
fazer a Bi pedância e etc e você ter
esses acompanhamentos mais rotineiros de
x em x Dias at a balança mas aí você não
precisa ir num lugar né e é tudo online
então tanto as receitas tipo as dicas e
coisas do tipo com consulta tudo online
e facilita o acompanhamento assim então
e Pô você acompanha tudo no app etc
Então cara vou trazendo mais updates vou
deixar o meu link aqui nos comentários
para quem quiser testar e ganhar 50% de
desconto na nem tão patrocinando viu p
[__] podia ser um patrocínio isso aqui
[__]
e mas vou deixar aí quem quiser testar
mas nos próximos episódios o App
funciona bem cara pesquisa isolado tipo
que você vai respondendo os negócios
super prático e enfim é isso da hora eu
conheci o Fernando que é um dos
co-founders da Caraca então manda um
abraço PR ele um abraço aí e realmente é
é uma ideia super legal assim é massa
que você tá Você tá curtindo tá com medo
de morrer né Art agora que você vai ter
agora que você vai se papai tá se
cuidando né pois não já tô me cuidando H
um tempo mas agora est me cuidando mais
mas eu eu me amarro em testar essas
porras né então
da hora é isso e o seu cara o meu é
oposto do Saudável né O meu é o a o
aplicativo de vinhos de clube de
assinatura de vinho que o BH faz frio né
mano e aí eu eu e a minha senhora a
gente entrou na onda de tomar vinho e aí
a real é que nem eu nem ela manj [__]
nenhuma de vinho então a gente decidiu
decidiu assinar um clube de vinhos aqui
que a gente recebe lá dois tdo bem qual
que você assinou Eu assino também eu
assino deixa eu ver qual que ass eu
assinei o Wine o clube Wi Não então mas
qual o tipo qual o essencial o essencial
o basicão é que a gente não conhece nada
aí falou assim Ah vamos nesse que a
gente vai aprendendo Vai vendo o que que
a gente gosta e tal e aí cara chegou
aqui a caixinha da hora n o aplicativo
também é muito legal assim tudo tem o
conteúdo da revista no aplicativo tem a
explicação de cada vinho então para quem
assim como eu é um zero à esquerda no no
conhecimento de vinhos eu acho que é que
é uma boa se você quer aprender aí e não
é caro então super de boa de de assinar
E aí conhecendo mais muito bom o meu é o
eu eu quando eu comecei a Eu sou
estudante há muito tempo do e quando eu
comecei a assinar o meu também foi Nessa
onda eu assino o Wine Box refrescantes
refrescante vinho branco né essas coisas
é e tal Porque eu curto mais meu Paladar
infantil gosto de
negócio gosto de uma coisa mais docinha
etc Vem uns vinh lá que sua garganta
fica mais seca do que molhada aí eu
falei não dá um negó mais justo justo eu
ainda vou chegar eu acho que eu não
descobri ainda Tipo o que que eu gosto
de fato daqui uns meses talvez tá bom e
que galera mandou pra gente aí P Hoje
teve muita gente mandando apesar da
gente ainda se mandar Aos 45 do segundo
tempo né Como sempre né mas o Cloves
Olha só o Cloves mandou do figma lives
Falou cara para quem faz os protótipos
lá no figma etc para montar a
apresentação tá tipo puro suco da
Integração ali olha aí fica a referência
que a gente falou aqui num dos nossos
Episódios do podcast do Len com com a
mirica capur que era a PM por trás do
figma slides então e também falamos do
da conferência do figma
nos
exato tudo se referencia Pois é né como
diria Steve Jobs nada se tomar no cu
cara nada se cria tudo se transforma
segue aí Segue aí com os prod da semana
da Galera o o danira falou do da seguro
que cara deu um pau no carro dele lá ele
rapidinho
deu resolveu lá fazendo no no app o
Glauco falou do aplicativo da Nespresso
essa coisa não me não me atinge mais que
agora eu sou né um Cofe ca mas você não
toma mas você não toma café não eu tomo
café mas agora eu faço meu próprio café
minha máquina Express blá blá blá Ah não
vou te falar aqui uma cápsul Zinha para
tomar um ali depois do almoço na
praticidade muito de manhã eu gosto de
fazer mas depois do almoço a Karina
mandou nock knx que é o app de do
condomínio dela lá daqui a pouco eu até
perguntei para ela se tem as tretas do
condomínio porque né os grupos do
condomínio sempre tem as tretas rapaz
teve aqui né Deixa
quieto depois depois depois conta ai
conta ai o bri mandou mandou YouTube
Premium que ae falou que mudou a vi dele
e olha eu eu me me compadeço porque
também depois que eu assinei o YouTube
Premium minha vida nunca mais foi a
mesma assim então eu eu ainda tô
sobrevivendo é o O Lucas mandou o
abastece aí falou que ajudou a
economizar um dinheirinho o chará desse
Lucas o outro Lucas mandou o
cling o kau mandou um é que você vai
gostar X
ingresso.com esse aí tem dedo meu deve
ter bug meu deve ter bug com a minha
assinatura lá até hoje
é e a pilon e o neui ó tem um app duplo
hoje dupla indicação falaram do estrava
travinha Então é isso acho que é isso
continue mandando pra gente pede aí
último vou até olhar de novo aqui para
ver se mais alguém mandou já que a gente
mandou agora os 40 em cima da hora como
sempre como sempre outra outra coisa aí
que a gente sempre fala que vai fazer
mas nunca faz é no início do programa
pedir pra galera ir lá e interagir né
Vai lá interage com os nossos posts
quando a gente publica o programa
comenta comenta no Spotify comenta no
subte no
subsc comenta no YouTube tudo isso ajuda
para caramba as plataformas entenderem
que vocês estão gostando do programa e a
indicar para mais pessoas Então deixa lá
seu comentario Zinho seu like suas cinco
estrelas coloca na playlist segue se
você não segue Ainda ajuda lá a gente
que e Indica né porque se cada pessoa
que houve esse programa trouxer mais um
ouvinte a gente dobra de tamanho não é
assim que a matemática funciona é isso
não PR especialista falando de
comentários e coisas do tipo eu queria
mandar aqui um salve pra Marina
Fernandes tá sempre mandando pra gente o
app da semana essa semana ela não mandou
mas ela tá sempre mandando Mas ela
comentou ela inclusive comentou do
último os últimos episódios falando que
cara a gente falou ela mandou no último
episódio ela mandou o nmade e o Wise e
no episódio anterior ela comentou aqui
também que o favorito o episódio
favorito dela é o Episódio 39 também que
você falou que era o seu Olha aí Tamos
junto Marina Marina é nós tá vendo a
gente falou que ia pegar aqui um
comentário na última edição para ler
nessa pegamos aqui e na semana que vem
pode ser o seu é só você ir lá deixa um
comentário pra gente em qualquer
plataforma que a gente lê aqui é
[Música]
isso e com isso a gente encerra o
programa de hoje com isso a gente
encerra né cara e semana que vem a gente
tá de volta é isso além dos recados já
dados segue a gente lá nas redes
@produces